[Music]
what makes you happy
would more money a new relationship job
or maybe even a pet make you happier
maybe to be happier you should give up
all of these things and go meditate on
the top of a mountain
or perhaps happiness is out of your
control
and you're just programmed to enjoy it a
lot
or a little
if you want to have a truly happy life
what do you need to focus on what should
your goals be
these questions have puzzled humanity
forever and many people think they can't
be answered
it turns out that there's a huge body of
science on human happiness who has it
what causes it and the biggest mistakes
we all make when we're trying to acquire
it
this is a course that brings all this
information to you
but it does more than just give you
facts and data
it also teaches you how to use it in
your life so you can get happier no
matter where you start out i'll show you
how philosophy social science history
and brain science all come together to
give us the secret to living fuller more
meaningful lives
and i'll teach you the exercises you
need to make these secrets a permanent
part of your life
and share them with the people you love
everybody wants to be happier
you can make yourself happier and this
course will show you how
[Music]
you